now we've mixed up things a little bit
more on the left side of the scale not
only do we have these identical unknown
masses with mass x these three blue
things we also have some of the one
kilogram masses over here we actually
have two of them so now we're going to
try to figure out what x is but before
we even do that what i want you to think
about is a mathematical equation that
can represent what is going on right
here that equates what we have on the
left hand here to what we have on the
right side of the scale right over there
and i'll give you a few seconds to think
about it
so let's think about what we have on the
left side here we have three
masses with mass x so you could say that
we have three x
over here we have three x's and then we
have two masses of one kilogram so in
total we have two kilograms so plus two
so one way to think about the total mass
on the left hand side is three x plus
two three masses with mass x plus two
kilograms that's what we have on the
left-hand side now let's think about
what we have on the right-hand side we
just have to count these we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen 14 14 blocks each
have a mass of one kilogram so the total
mass right over here is going to be 14
kilograms
so we get and we see that the scale is
balanced it's not tilting down or
upwards so the scale is balanced so this
mass this total mass right over here
must be equal to this total mass the
scale is balanced so we can write
we can write an equal sign let me do
that in that white color i don't like
that brown we can do it in that white
color now what i want you to think about
and you can think about it either
through the symbols or think about it
through the scale is
how would you go about we'll think about
a few things how would you first go
about at least getting rid of these
these little one kilogram blocks over
here and i'll give you a second to think
about that
well the simplest thing is well you
could take these one kilogram blocks off
of the left hand side but remember if
you just took these one kilogram blocks
off the left hand side and it was
balanced before now the left-hand side
will be lighter and it will move up but
we want to keep it balanced so that we
can keep saying equal that this mass is
equal to that mass so if we're going to
remove two blocks from the left-hand
side we need to remove two blocks from
the right-hand side so we can remove two
there and then we can remove two right
over there and mathematically what we're
essentially doing is we're subtracting
two kilograms from each side so we're
subtracting two from this side so on the
left-hand side we now have 3x plus 2
minus 2 we're just left with 3x
we're just left with 3x and on the right
hand side we had 14 and we took away 2.
let me write this we took away 2 so
we're going to be left with 12.
we're going to be left with 12 blocks
and you see that there the ones that i
haven't crossed out there's 12 left and
here you only have three of those x
boxes and since we removed the exact
same amount from both sides our scale is
still balanced and our equation 3x is
now equal to 12. and now this is turns
into a problem very similar to what we
saw in the last video so i will ask you
what can we do to isolate 1x to only
have one x on the scale while keeping
the scale or one x on the left hand side
of the scale while keeping the scale
balanced
so the easiest way to think about it is
i have if i want one x on this left hand
side that's one third of the total x is
here so what if i were to essentially
multiply the left hand side by one third
but if i want to keep the scale balanced
i have to multiply the right hand side
by one third and so if we can do that
mathematically so right over here i can
multiply the left-hand side by one-third
but if i want to keep my scale balance i
also have to keep the right-hand side i
have to multiply the right-hand side by
one-third and multiplying it physically
this literally means just keeping
one-third of what we had here originally
so we would get rid of two of these and
if we want to keep one third of what we
had here originally there are 12 blocks
left over after removing those first two
so one third of 12 we're only going to
keep four blocks four boxes four of
these little one kilogram boxes left so
let me remove let me remove all but four
so we're going to move those and remove
those i have left one two three four
here
and so what you're left with the only
thing you have left is this x
this x i'll shade it in to show this is
the one that we actually have left and
then we have these boxes we have these 1
kilogram boxes and you see it
mathematically right over here 1 3 times
3x or you could have said 3x divided by
3 either way that gives us
that you could say that these threes
cancel out that'll give you just an x
and then on the right hand side 12 times
1 3 which is the same thing as 12
divided by 3 is equal to 4.
and since we did the same thing to both
sides the scale is still balanced and so
you see that the mass of this thing must
be the same thing as the mass of these
four leftover blocks x must be equal to
4 kilograms